[Musik]
seine schnauze ist inzwischen grau aber
für frauchen nara ist es immer noch die
große hunde liebe und das trotz eines
jahrzehnts pause denn cockerspaniel
robbie und seine besitzerin waren ganze
zehn jahre voneinander getrennt nur
durch zufall entdeckte die 25-jährige
ihren vierbeiner im tierheim erfurt es
war zufall entdeckt habe weil ich meinen
hund haben wollte
irgendwie hatte ich so eine intuition
ich guck mal im tierheim erst noch mal
und da habe ich ein bild gesehen habe
ich eine umgucken bei dem bild von der
seite wusste ich einfach dass er das ist
weiß seinen nasenform so gut noch in
erinnerung hat und er hat tatsächlich
sehr lange ohren im juli 2010 riss der
damals vierjährige rocky in erfurt aus
trotz wochenlanger suche blieb er
verschwunden was frauchen aber nicht
wusste rocky landete damals im tierheim
dann lebte er unter dem namen black ii
bei einer älteren frau bis diese
verstarb um kurz darauf wieder im
tierheim zu landen
lara kontaktiert sofort das tierheim und
vereinbarte ein treffen allerdings hält
sich die wiedersehensfreude zunächst in
grenzen jedenfalls von rocky slater aus
also ja das wiedersehen war ein bisschen
kalt stellte auch welche wachsenden und
vielleicht auch anders aussehe und
visionär anders hört und er sich auch
verändert hat meine mutter getroffen und
in meinem papa auch und inzwischen
weicht ricky seinem ex frauchen kaum
noch von der seite
der clevere cockerspaniel scheint sich
die verpassten streiche rationen der
vergangenen zehn jahre einzuholen
seinen lebensabend wird er definitiv bei
lara verbringen
[Musik]